how are you doing today sir good to see
you Steve where are you that's a cool
backdrop there uh so you're seeing I'm
in Brazil I'm at a convention called
ccxp which is the one of the biggest
Comic Cons in the world biggest one in
Latin America it's like 10 minutes from
closing but you can sort of see uh how
insane it is it looks incredible like
it's it's uh it's effing crazy if you
want to know the truth like look at it
no it is it's like I was thinking maybe
that's your day-to-day office where
we're like talking from if we had talked
like 20 minutes ago you would have seen
Keanu Reeves and like just like
thousands of people here it was insane
you know but anyway enough of that uh I
just want to say congrats on the movie
and I don't make I don't appreciate you
making me cry so um you know F you I'm
joking obviously
thanks for watching it and I'm you know
but you know it's a life-affirming film
at the end and I hope it made it off as
well listen uh 100 100 as yeah yes
um well I definitely want to talk to the
fact that uh Tom Hanks is one of the
greatest actors of all time and what is
it like actually collaborating with
someone like that who literally could
make reading a phone book phenomenal uh
you know it's just incredible because
everything you hear about him is true
he's not just the the nicest person in
Hollywood it's all true that he's the
that couldn't be in my dreams a better
collaborator he has no ego he's so kind
and he listens and and we've just been
working you know working together with
someone that good as you said one of the
greatest actors of all time I mean it's
it's extraordinary and
and it's someone playing his instrument
on the highest level and you're just
trying to hear if there was one wrong
note and it's you know after two three
takes you move on because it's just all
there yeah I I can't imagine so um one
of the things they say is to not work
with animals babies or children and so
you chose to work with a cat a baby and
two children at what point of the shoot
were you like what did I get myself into
uh you know when I was looking at the
weather in Pittsburgh but but I think
the cat schmeagle was probably the
toughest one schmeagle had you know
sometimes shebago just didn't just left
said and walked off and then and then I
had to I beg the producer for a green
screen they were because I don't like CG
animals and CG cats so we then we kept
shooting the Smeg on a green screen and
then to complement to the into the into
the picture but ultimately it's 90 it's
all schmeagle's performance so I was
very happy with that but that that was
much harder than the kid or anything
else yeah you know something I I have
cats um and they they sometimes don't
want to do anything that you want them
to do but so one of the things I love
cats and I want to know if you agree
that one of the morals of this movie is
that uh a cat can help save your life
absolutely and I think and the cat can
become your best friends and it's
unconditional love until they get very
mad at you yes all right yeah I I don't
know having a cat yet scratch at me I
think you know this about me but I love
talking about the editing process
because that's where it all comes
together and one of the things about
this movie is you need to find the right
tone to make what uh what oughta was
going through believable to the audience
uh because he's contemplating suicide
which is a very serious thing so can you
sort of talk about finding the right
tone and the right takes in the editing
room to make sure the audience felt what
they needed to feel you know obviously I
was very uh blessed because there was a
uh you know the novel there and
Frederick Beckman did a great job in the
novel balancing it and there was the
Swedish version of the film which also
did a very good job with that so there
was Source material but then once we got
into the editing you know we did I did a
lot of the ins and outs of the
flashbacks which often happens during
during the suicide attempts there were
often these moments where I had Tom play
them and then Truman play play them as
well Truman Hanks who plays the younger
younger Otto and and then use a lot of I
don't know if you realize that we lose a
lot of the soundtrack as well too to
sort of Gap the bridges for instance the
Kate Bush song in the the moment later
in the movie between present day and the
past so you have this continuous and
emotional bandage between the two worlds
that it doesn't take you out but it was
really the Silver Lining trying to find
the humor in the dark and the Darkness
the yin and the Yang to really uh you
know it took a while but eventually I
think we got there that I'm really
pleased and I hope you know in the
people because it's about a community
coming together I hope that Community
like experienced the movie in a theater
because they can laugh and cry together
listen I I've said this again and again
nothing should be watched movies need to
be seen on the biggest screen possible I
mean there's nothing like seeing a movie
in a movie theater thanks Steve yeah I
agree and special especially movies like
this 100
um so what what did you learn from any
friends and family screenings or test
screenings that impacted the finished
film did you make any big change because
the you know from what people said no I
must say we're very very blessed our
first test screening was in New Jersey
and the 10 and the movie tested really
high and uh you know and people really
embraced the movie and they laughed and
they cried and they had all pretty much
factions but we just kept on work on it
and then had another test screening
after that and kept editing it and
finessing it and it's you know how it is
it's you massaging your massaging and we
still probably if the movie wouldn't
come out we still would be editing yeah
I've I've spoken to a lot of directors
basically say uh it's taken out of their
cold dead hands you know uh because they
just want to keep anyway
um so I have to ask you what is actually
I've been looking forward to seeing
white bird uh one your story but when am
I going to see it it's coming out next
year uh Lionsgate had you know a change
in the marketing team as you know uh so
there's a new team in now and they're
all very excited and and I love the
movie personally I can't wait for you to
see it
it's uh you know
it's a it's a departure but anytime when
you're back from Brazil I'm happy
I'm happy to set up a screening for you
anytime Steve listen I I do want to see
it um my last question for you you've
done so many different projects and so
many different genre you've made a lot
of movies a lot of projects of your
career what shot do you think ended up
being the hardest to pull off and why
um you know I think it was early in my
career it was like in finding
Netherlands there was sort of a a crane
shot through the theater and just ending
up right in on on Freddie Highmore
and on his face and uh when you know
ultimately when he's watching uh you
know the creation of himself uh of Peter
Pan and and that shot because I wasn't I
wasn't at that point used to to work
with such big equipment because you know
Monster Ball was all very low budget and
then suddenly finally ever had a crane
and I had this techno crane that sort of
like had this uh which had emotional
control and all these things on it and
and I I just like was scared that the
camera would hit the kid or something so
so because it came so close but they all
said oh no it's all safe don't worry
about it and it was just wasn't it so so
used to it that I was instead of
watching the shot I was just once
worried that that that that he will be
safe because the camera was like flying
in into him and and then stopped at a
certain point and you know which they
say it's safe and everything else and
they tested it ten thousand times but
still that that kind of shot just
emotionally like yes I wanted to share
that storyboarded and had in my mind but
I said oh how are we going to execute oh
it's not not a problem we can do this
very easily so that was uh that we you
know we ended pulling it off I'm just
gonna have to stop I'm just gonna say
congrats I hope the movie's a big hit
for you and thank you for giving me your
time okay and thank you enjoy your time
in South America